in the battle against Thanos the day was
ultimately won by a tiny unlikely hero
and now oh not that one but you close
during a spoiler filled interview with
the Chinese website Avengers end game
co-director Joe Russo let slip the true
hero of the film though if you're
anything like us it had probably already
crossed your mind that the Avengers
victory would never have been possible
if not for a random Mouse of course the
key to the Avengers eventual victory was
actually Scott Lang he was last seen in
the post-credits scene for ant-man and
the wasp stranded in the quantum realm
after Hank Pym Janet Van Dyne and hope
Van Dyne who were to pull him out once
he was finished collecting healing
particles for their new friend ghosts
were all dusted before they could throw
the switch and bring Scott back at the
start of endgame we learned that during
the five years since the snap inning the
van in which the quantum tunnel was
housed had been sitting in a rodent
infested storage in a fourteen million
to one shot one of those rodents just
happened to crawl across the exact right
spot on the tunnels control panel
zapping Scott back into the world for it
in time a few alternate futures how many
did you see 14 million six hundred five
how many we win this raises the question
if not for that Mouse would Thanos have
won if it would have crawled across a
different portion of the panel even
would the Avengers have been hosed
according to Rousseau the answer is yes
the mouse saved the universe among the
many realities in those fourteen million
possible futures Doctor Strange foresaw
the maus failed to press the button and
thus the heroes failed in those futures
that's just insane yes the Avengers plan
to reverse the decimation was a
convoluted one with different teams
traveling to different time periods in
order to preemptively acquire all six
Infinity stones before Thanos could get
his hands on them it was also fraught
with complications Tony Stark and Steve
Rogers failed to grab the tesseract
during the Battle of New York
necessitating a slight detour to 1970
like Gamora before her black widow was
forced to give her life in exchange for
the soul stone and 2014 Thanos figured
out the whole plan due to nebula sinker
into that period almost managing to
thwart our heroes by sending the still
villainous past version of nebula to the
present as a mole but since we know that
dr. strange saw the only outcome that
resulted in victory during his future
viewing party on Titan during Avengers
infinity war we know that somehow it all
played out exactly like it was supposed
to and that included the contribution of
that lowdown dirty mouse think about
what must have been going through dr.
Strange's mind when he handed the time
stone over to Thanos knowing that the
future of the universe depended on the
random wanderings of a mouse five years
in the future we suppose that one could
take it even further making the case
that the universe was really saved by
whatever anonymous towing company
employee decided to move Scott's van to
that crappy storage facility rather than
a nice urn on vermin-infested one or the
security guard who let Scott out of the
locked facility rather than calling the
cops on the wild-eyed stranger who had
suddenly appeared in said facility out
of nowhere there were a lot of moving
parts to the whole thing but in the end
we've got to go with the word of
rousseau a mouse was responsible for
half of all life in the universe being
restored which we're sure has nothing to
do with the fact that Marvel Studios is
owned by Disney it's doubtful that
laying even knows exactly how he was
freed which is a real shame because at
the very least that Mouse deserves a
medal or perhaps an honorary membership
in the avengers so next time you think
about the Avengers saving the universe
remember as much as we all love Captain
America and Iron Man I only hope that we
never lose sight of one thing that was
all started by a map check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about Marvel are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]